yeah I'm just gonna make some copies in
here
perfect cover nailed it so apparently
the new captain survived and his heart
attack not the craziest thing that
happened at the precinct today
we kissed three hours ago yes we did
kiss each other for reals reels reels
listen I know you said you don't want to
date cops but
I really like you
I like you too good but what's our
dating and it makes things weird at work
so let's just
keep it light and Breezy
see where it goes totally yeah so how do
we keep it light and Breezy
I know a comprehensive set of rules how
am I attracted to you doesn't matter I
am go rule one let's not tell anyone so
we can figure out what this is first
smart rule number two let's not put
labels on it we're not boyfriend or
girlfriend we're just mermzy pen jingle
bin Great rule number three let's not
have sex right away
cool cool
Ames you're two minutes late I called
all the emergency rooms I know I went
home from your place to shower and I'm
so tired that I fell asleep while
shaving my legs we went to bed so early
Property Brothers was over a tenth I
mean
sex we do it she's tired from all the
doing it
there you are thank God hey how'd you
find me January 14 2014 detectives
Peralta and Santiago conducted
surveillance from a rooftop at 397
Barton Street this is where we came the
night I won our bet and you fell in love
with me Jake the night that you flirted
with me for 20 seconds and I became
obsessed with you forever ready
I'm sorry I freaked out and ran away
it's okay just because you messed up the
practice test doesn't mean you're gonna
fail the real one I didn't mess it up I
got 102 I found a spelling error and one
question I gave myself extra credit
then why'd you leave because that was
the first time it really hit me
when I passed the exam I'll actually be
a sergeant
what if everything changes between us
that's why you came here
things are so good right now
by
preferred or becoming your boss James
I've always known you were going to be
my boss I mean this is your dream from
before we were dating and yeah things
might change a little but for the better
right you can finally get premium cable
check out all those shows on epics
look you can't be afraid to be
successful you're too good for that
I love you love you too
wait the test we gotta get you out of
here right I'm gonna be a surgeon I'm
gonna be a sergeant
you don't have a key for this random
roof door do you it's called taxi
because it's yellow and it takes you
where you need to be drug dealers have
gotten so creative it used to just be
crack and then they'd be like hey we got
a new one what are we gonna call this
and they'd go I don't know crank this is
certainly worth following up on Santiago
take a ball and work the case oh but
Jake I mean detective Peralta brought in
the perps so good point uh peralt and
Boyle can break the case actually sir I
think we were kind of hoping we could
work the case together oh are you two no
longer smushing booties
yes that's exactly I was going to finish
my sentence figured we are still dating
it's all above board HR gets daily
updates and rbcc'd on all our emails to
each other that's why HR gym keeps
high-fiving me we begin we're all great
stories begin in the quaint little town
a french fry Village after that we're
gonna move our adventure over to
Cheeseburger Mountain which consists do
you guessed it of turkey burgers I'm
kidding it's cheeseburgers this is kind
of just stuffing you can avoid that but
it's attached to the Thanksgiving turkey
theme because I was thinking about that
a lot up in the jail and finally we have
a big old Passover brisket because you
know I love my mom if you would all take
while I make a toast
kindly raise your two liters
to freedom to you and most importantly
to orange drink
and sex with Amy
sorry should have said that last part
hey honey thanks for bringing Roger back
you're very welcome hey by the way
Amy was really nervous to meet you so
don't judge her too harshly for all the
weird singing oh no I'm dating my son of
a [__] ex-husband who am I to judge
you're really great too
she's very good at lip reading I
wouldn't say I'm
saying I'm deaf people
people just can't stop
he's leaving our plan works we saved our
own honeymoon and fun bonus we cheered
up halt yes okay it's time to celebrate
you know what that means this bee needs
a c in her a oh my God this babe needs a
coconut in her arms Oh I thought you
were saying this music oh my God that
was my reaction all right I'll go get us
a couple of coconuts thinking how did
anyone swap my key and then it hit me
they didn't they swapped the safe one of
the handmaids I'm assuming fake Charles
took my safe and then of Amy deposited a
look-alike
who did you give fake Charles so he'd
help you nothing in fact he gave me
something the power of Financial Freedom
I invested in a pyramid scheme it's no
time to go into it right now okay
so while we all tried to figure out who
had the real key fake Charles broke into
the safe removed the tracker and let
Terry and the whole squad on a wild
goose chase my only question is which
box is the belt in wow good luck
figuring it out because the clock is
Tick Tick tocking it's that one no the
dust pattern on top doesn't match its
neighbors
you see Jake I'm always gonna be one
step ahead of you you've lost the
ability to surprise me you just plain
boring again weird take on a very loving
relationship and it's midnight so I
guess I'm an amazing human slash genius
yeah
although
you might want to read the inscription
on that they're built why oh no what
does it say
Amy Santiago will you marry me
surprise
I'm so confused I don't know what's
happening right now I'm so confused I
don't know what's happening right now
title your sex tape
shaking I'm definitely gonna cry titled
your sex tape wait is this really
happening is this part of the heist if
this is part of the heist I will dump
you so hard no please hey it's like it's
really happening okay
a part of the heist I promise this is
where you are I love how beautiful you
are I love your face and I love your
butt I should have written this down
first no no it's okay go on I love how
much you pretend to like die hard I like
the second one you don't have to okay
yeah
you're kind and you're funny and you're
the best person I know and
the best detective
also for reals I love your butt I love
yours too gross
Amy Santiago
will you marry me
Jake Peralta I will marry you
I love you so much hey it's your goes
this little [__] Escape so that ought
to teach
you just and did you say
hey Gina just texted me she said weird I
didn't even realize they were dating JK
so happy for you [__]
so Jake tell us everything did you call
any stat first I actually did Mr
Santiago I'm calling to inform you that
I plan to ask your daughter to marry me
but
it's 2017 I am not asking for your
permission as she is not your property
nor would she be mine if she chooses to
say yes she's a strong independent woman
and she don't need no man that being
said I truly hope she says yes but it's
her decision so just back up
perfect
I have no idea I left a voicemail I'm
terrified of him not to talk out of turn
but I think I get credit for giving Jake
the idea to propose
what I'm saying is vanilla
Illinois with a blueberry
blueberry and both of them taste even
better get it
yes I did not get it but speaking of
yogurt you've eaten six GPS devices this
week you should definitely see a doctor
what look Sarge I think everyone knows
that I planted the idea in Jake's head
eight years ago oh hi I'm starting today
detective Santiago oh detective Peralta
welcome aboard
I'm hearing Wedding Bells
hi detective Boyle that actually really
slowed things down it took like four
years for me to forget that memory yeah
My Own Worst Enemy look no one gave me
the idea I decided to ask Amy to marry
me all on my own on April 28th
there's a typo in this crossword puzzle
I don't get it seems pretty normal I
don't know what to tell you
romantic epiphanies are dope thank you
Rosa please be seated
friends
colleagues gawking New Yorkers
we are here today to celebrate the
marriage of Jake Peralta and Amy
Santiago I've known you both for the
last five years and it has been a true
pleasure to watch your distracting
childish rivalry evolve into a
distracting childish courtship and now
into what I'm sure will be a distracting
childish marriage
I'm proud of you
and I love you both permission to say it
back permission grounded
foreign